now tamale were at least 53 soldiers and
one civilian have been killed in an
attack on a military base in the
northeast of the country it was carried
out on an outpost in the Menaka region
so far no groups claimed responsibility
now this is just the latest in a series
of attacks in the Sahel region on
September the 30th two Malian military
bases were targeted by fighters linked
to al-qaeda the government said 38
soldiers were killed but it's feared
that actually more than that died the
violence isn't limited to Mali recent
attacks have taken place in neighboring
Burkina Faso and in Nazaire groups
claiming allegiance to ISIL and I cut
al-qaeda as well as Boko Haram have all
contributed to instability across the
region the violence has escalated
despite international intervention with
the backing of France five countries
have created a 5,000 strong g5 Sahel
force to tackle the armed groups and
there are also UN peacekeepers there
our correspondent Mohamed Val has
reported extensively in the region he
has more on the challenges in Mali
it's very clear that the the campaign
that has been going on for years
actually since 2012 has has failed to to
finish those groups there despite the
convergence of thousands and thousands
of troops 5,000 you have mentioned from
the g5 countries including Mali and four
other
Sahel countries you have thousands from
France and you and has also a big
existence there UN peacekeepers despite
those efforts despite those armies it's
very clear that that campaign has not
given the results that were intended and
that's probably according to analysts
because the intention itself many
accused those troops of not really being
there only to finish that phenomenon of
so-called terrorism in the region but
also countries have interests they have
interests in staying there for a long
time and coordination with the Malian
government also is faltering because
they accuse the modern government of not
doing its share we have
seen those defeats after defeats by them
against the Malian army accusations
there that whatever is given whatever is
done whatever help is given to the
Malian army it's not making this army
prepared enough to face the threat we
also have the vast desert the fact that
those thousands and thousands of
kilometers of the Sahel are
uncontrollable those troops also from
foreign countries are not really going
out chasing those groups but mainly
staying in big cities and mainly
concerned about their own safety so lots
of intricate factors they're playing
role our role in making this operation
very difficult and making it less
fruitful